so i had my old old intro uh so my
current intro now is made by my friend
from uni yeah who used to be like a
music producer and it's like not even
out on like any website yeah so i know
it's like good it's like all you know
copyright free because i had the exact
same thing where like i saw like i went
on to like soundcloud and i found like
this really like bang a song yeah um
and uh and i was like i'll call use it
as an outro because it's like kind of
wacky goofy like you know all the gaming
youtubers are using it at the time and
then of course uh that artist got really
popular on soundcloud
because every youtuber was using it got
a major record label because of it and
then the record label copyright claimed
all of my [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and uh and i had
and same thing i like dm the artist i
was like yeah so what's happening uh you
said i could use it she's like
yeah but i'm like a big shot now
i'm like i got a major record label and
i'm unfortunate i can't do anything for
you but luckily this was during the time
where again youtube introduced the
muting thing so yeah shitty of them to
not if you asked did you ask them
permission initially yeah yeah so i
asked the uh so i dm the artist
initially when she was just on
soundcloud and she was like yeah please
go for it like i love that like just
just you know obviously just [ __ ] up
just like just like just link it in the
description you'll be all good i was
like oh sorry that's very nice of her
and uh and then yeah she was like oh
sorry that's uh my that's not that's not
my decision that's my labels decision so
sorry
so then i had to yeah so like if you go
back to like videos from like 2017 the
way i use that outro oh they're all mute
at the end yeah i've got a lot of videos
where it's just me talking at the end i
still got comments to say like why does
it like just go silent
yeah man yeah i mean i've had to use
that feature for like some of my videos
but like i don't mute it i just like cut
out like the yeah now i can replace the
music yeah you can replace the music
because i believe we had to do that for
trash taste or something right because
that got copyright claimed or something
one of the specials or something oh yeah
and after dark as well for some reason
our intro for trash chase called
copyright claims and after that on
twitch
song yeah it's a royalty free song but
we're just like no no no no
well a couple right the corporate
systems unfortunately are like are
really easy to abuse like you can stick
any old [ __ ] piece of music and start
claiming [ __ ] and it's only until
somebody like stops you yeah yeah so you
know it was like the weirdest copyright
claimed
i've gotten is like for like anime music
that i've put into my videos well like
before like anime osc's were just like
free game because
japan the anime industry didn't really
give a [ __ ] and now they're slowly
coming to realize wait a minute
youtubers use our music
how can how can this be so like now
anime osts are starting to be claimed as
well yeah but i didn't get claimed by
one of the anime companies so i
in one of my videos i had you save run
on on it
um and i got claimed and you say ryan
got claimed but it didn't get claimed it
got claimed by a cover of you save run
what so a youtuber
a youtuber who i believe is signed with
a record label or made a video where
they made a cover of you say run and
that got like the original you say run
that i used in my video got claimed by a
cover of you save right right um and
yeah that's i i'd like where do i even
begin with that you know like that's uh
i mean yeah like super early in my
youtube channel i used to do like covers
of anime songs like on guitar and piano
and stuff like that yeah the reason why
i don't do that anymore is because the
few times i ever got a copyright strike
yeah not a claim a strike was from a
cover i did i did a cover of um i did a
cover of [ __ ] paranoid android by
radiohead because it was the ending to
ergo proxy right and at the time it was
like i really liked it yeah and uh yeah
i got a [ __ ] strike on it and i was
like
not sure if that can also be a humble
brag because that's like saying like you
are so good
youtube literally i thought it was the
real thought it was the original song i
was like thanks youtube but also what
the [ __ ] i've had my voice claimed a few
times actually really yeah my own videos
people trying to claim my like
they're like well i'm just talking
there's nothing is that so you don't va
yeah i've seen a tick tock of that
yeah
it's pretty bizarre it's like
i've never heard of that i'm not like an
original as one dude on youtube one time
he he uploaded his original song and
then got claimed by someone yeah someone
claimed his original song right right
that he uploaded to his own channel
well because anyone anyone could put
anything called
like these companies are given like you
know free reign yeah remember remember
there was like i forgot when it was it
was like maybe 2018 there was like that
copyright armageddon that was happening
where yeah yeah all these like fake
companies were like going around
i mean it's still happening because like
it's not as bad as it used to be though
it's not it definitely isn't and i'm
glad like one of the positive things
youtube has done is given creators tools
to like for example cut or mute the
segment that has been copyright claimed
out which we just didn't have before so
if we got copyright claimed before for
like a second of music then there was
just like nothing we could do it was
just like a dead video yeah man you know
what companies suck what there's [ __ ]
like viral hog and all those dudes the
ones that like buy viral videos oh
go around claiming them like armageddon
they're [ __ ] awful like nine gag and
stuff like that no no no they're like
these you know when you see those
watermarks on facebook you know remember
that video of that dude punching the
kangaroo yeah bible uh kind kind of like
that but a bit different because live
bible they don't really they don't
normally go around copyright claims yeah
that that video right the the person who
had that video sold it to this company
right and then what they do is everyone
who's then uh talking about it or
showing it they'll just go around
copyright claiming everything any of
these news networks
well it's the business model like they
they buy these videos for like very
cheap
like have you have you never had offers
from people who want to buy your videos
they'll go around buying them and then
just claim everything and it's just yeah
it's really [ __ ] and because people
react to stuff on stream as well you
know yeah that's true and also the worst
thing is about that luckily 99 of you
will never have to experience is that
these copyright claims right sometimes
they're like really [ __ ] generous
with the timing on the video like so
they have to say what time in the video
they copyright claire yeah yeah and
sometimes they'll add on like five or
ten seconds oh yeah
i'm like a piece of [ __ ] now i've gotta
like this this it was like a clear edit
and everything i've gotta edit out or
mute [ __ ] because yeah because you don't
get to contest no time so whatever the
time is that's like if you want to mute
the the copyrighted content you don't
get to say where it is yeah whatever
they submitted is it so one time on one
video i remember i reacted to like a
clip or something on like on a live
stream or something on connor talk and
uh they claimed it and i was like yeah
it's fair enough but then they claimed
like 40 seconds extra of nothing to do
with said club wow and i was like wow
dude like really like like a four shirt
they own your reaction as well
apparently no no
[ __ ] my
videos like that where i've react shadow
and i don't give a [ __ ] but yeah it's
like bro what are you doing don't claim
[ __ ] that isn't the video like come on
you're just lazy
that's the problem right it's like i
feel like youtube has done a really good
job of like trying to make the playing
field as fair as possible right like
yeah only recently they added that whole
thing of like
how uh during an appealing process the
money that the video accumulates goes
into what's called escrow which is like
kind of what you should have done yeah
yeah it's kind of like it doesn't go to
the
person who is the supposed copyright
holder or the video owner it kind of
like is floating in the cloud until it's
resolved yeah it's just great it's like
being put in the pool yeah no one can
get that until the uh copyright
situation is resolved which is fantastic
but like at the same time even today i
feel the
you know the advantage is still in the
claimant yeah like clearly youtube is
like yeah you know obviously if you're
gonna go out of your way to claim
something copyright-wise then you must
have a good reason for it but a lot of
companies don't